so earlier this year i talked about a
court case involving rapper tory lanez
and female rapper meg the stallion i
would say that meg the stallion is one
of the biggest names in the game right
now really being pushed by the industry
machine i guess i understand the appeal
of her music to some people but there's
other female artists i would much rather
listen to i'm not saying i dislike her
and i do think she's actually very
talented the music is really just not
for me but when it comes to this court
case it appears she might have been the
girl who cried wolf because tory lanez
is not backing down at all i 100 believe
tory thinks he is going to walk away
from this situation a free man for those
of you that don't know what happened
this guy tori lanes and meg the stallion
were having this alleged relationship
for months during 2020 and one night in
july of last year they were hanging out
with kylie jenner along with his
bodyguard and the stallion's former best
friend kelsey allegedly make the
stallion got them kicked out of kylie
jenner's mansion for being obnoxious so
they had to abruptly leave after they
had all been drinking and the way magnus
stallion tells it on that ride back to
the hotel tori shot her in the foot
after a heated argument but when the car
later got pulled over megan told the
police that the wounds on her feet were
due to her stepping on glass something
she later said that she lied about out
of fear of what the police might do to
someone in the car tmz actually had
video of the whole thing going down and
you can see the car where she says tory
shot her in the end tori was arrested on
a gun charge and walked two days later
but one month after the alleged incident
megan went on instagram live to try and
air out tory lanez saying that he shot
her in a drunken rage and that she
covered for him because he's her friend
who was on probation and of course the
part about her not trusting the police
everybody in the car arguing
i'm in the front seat this [ __ ] in the
back seat
i'll get out the car i'm done arguing i
don't want to argue no more i'll get out
i'm walking away
this [ __ ] from out the back seat of the
car starts shooting me you shot me i
didn't get cut by no glass but let me
tell you why they saying that but tori
says that this is all [ __ ] that he's
been framed like roger rabbit she also
claims on that day that they had nothing
intimate going on when they were
chilling like this every day she also
says that she should have sent him to
jail but she decided to spare him you
scared to come tell everybody that you
[ __ ] shot me and you got your whole
[ __ ] team on the internet lying in
response tori had this to say you get
out of the car because the heated
argument is so heated and then this
person gets out and shoots you in both
of your feet and you jump back in the
car why would you jump back in the car
with a dangerous man who just did a
dangerous crime to you who did this
criminal intent to you and all this all
this
what why he then throws the black card
at me i'm trying to protect this black
man
my love nobody ever reported that you
got shot but you so why are you how are
you trying to protect me i'm not
protecting somebody who just heinously
shot me after a conversation that we
just had i'm not my mind is not on
protecting you i'm bleeding from my feet
i'm thinking about protecting my own
life and i'm in danger why would you not
say that with two feet bleeding from two
bullet holes from what you're saying how
can you identify who's shooting at you
if you're facing the other way how can
you i even identify criminal or
malicious intent if you're not seeing
what's going on behind you that doesn't
even make sense he talks about being
conflicted on how to handle the
situation because his career was
obviously in danger of being destroyed
everyone in the media was already
framing him of being guilty before this
case ever even went to court or he even
had a chance to speak on it in fact i
would say a majority of people are still
in the belief that there's a zero
percent chance this guy is innocent
because they only base their opinions
from non-objective news sources from the
start this has basically been a he said
she said situation i'm not saying he's
innocent but three out of the four
people there that night aka everyone
besides meg the stallion including her
at the time best friend said that tori
didn't shoot her the police and medical
providers reported no gunshot wound in
her foot in the initial police report
and tori had no gunshot residue on his
body the night he was taken in jail she
posted this picture of her foot and she
posted a picture there's no bullet train
where are they taking out the bullets
for this for the for the pan like this
is what's going on like where are they
taking out the bullets for the pan i
don't understand like where's the
surgeon you're not in a surgical room
and anybody who knows i mean this is
like it clearly had to be the first day
that you've taken this picture two
sources close to the investigation said
that she had she got cut by glass and
she said that she got cut by glass tory
even came out with a whole album
explaining his innocence and has gone on
a campaign to try and clear his name
because the media storm assuming his
guilt was [ __ ] huge and quite frankly
unfair with a low amount of evidence she
has provided and based on how
questionable her story is there's no way
he should receive this much negative
coverage but as i said before she is
protected in the industry whereas he had
recently gone independent right before
this happens which is something record
labels really hate and the second y'all
have an accusation not even evidence
[ __ ] just come bash me i'm somebody
who just i don't get a save i get
shunned up they took me off of every
single playlist they took me off every
playlist they didn't want my story to
come out
they didn't allow my story to come out
and that was the truth at the time but
now the industry is rocking with tory
again and he's released some great
records since then joe biden and company
say him popping up with more brand
conscious celebrities is a clear sign
that the industry must feel confident in
his case to be innocent they recently
offered him a plea deal but he rejected
it giving me even more reason to believe
that he thinks he will win this case and
if he has proven innocent then her
career is done but if he is proven
guilty and goes to jail then i guess
there's some sort of evidence she's
hiding because as of right now her story
is really all over the place i mean now
she's saying that tori said dance [ __ ]
dance before shooting at her feet like
joe pesci when he shot spider and
goodfellas
so i guess we will have to see how this
plays out a lot of people are now
suspecting it was the former best friend
who shot her after she allegedly was
having an intimate relationship with
tory lanez himself she was the only one
with gun residue on her hands that night
and a third party witness now claims the
gun flash was closer to her than tori
look all i know is one day this is going
to be made into either a really good a
really cheesy ass movie i'm talking
about you're probably wondering how i
got here type b but let me know what you
guys think about the situation down
below are you team tory are you team
megan no harm no foul want to know down
below in the comments as always i also
want to thank you guys for watching
today's video and subscribing y'all
don't know how much it helps me when you
drop a big like or share the video with
a friend so i really appreciate that and
as you guys know it's been your boy the
tan superman and some of the [ __ ] out he
needs to get covered so i'm out
peace
jamari speaks he speaking facts no video
gotta watch that no kpon just a baseball
cap give me that social news no cap
click that link baby don't hold back hit
that replay bring it all back good
content he never lack watch one time i
gotta come back